people in Khartoum are living in the
middle of a war zone
what was once a bustling Market is now
piles of rubble buildings and homes are
in Ruins this burrito has
near my house here
we are suffering of lack of food lack of
ethnicity lack of water we do not have
electricity for three days now and also
we do not have
access to water
[Music]
people say relatives are missing but
they can't go out and search for them as
they're too scared to leave the house
doctors have described the situation as
catastrophic
the hospital is still operational but
not to the full capacity due to the
shortage of medical equipment let alone
difficulty the medical staff face to get
to work
oh
the fighting in the capital is
and the Army Headquarters this
are members of the paramilitary rapid
support forces with their Commander
General Muhammad hamdan daglow in the
area but it's not clear when it was
filmed
across the Nile River in the city of
omdurman some people are bearing their
dead this home was hit by shelling while
the family was asleep
I have burns on my body and I couldn't
stand up but God helped me many shells
came into my room and I collected them
they hid the room and came through the
window they broke the glass I was lying
in bed and when I stood up I fell to the
ground
in darduk north of Khartoum there are
pockets of resistance some people took
to the streets in protest on Saturday
calling for an end to the violence
analysts say Sudan's longer waited
transition to civilian rule a prospect
that seemed imminent a few weeks ago is
moving further Out Of Reach
[Music]
for as long as general Douglas and army
Chief Abdul fatah al-burhan refused to
back down one of them needs to win so
that he could claim power this is how
they see it from both ends uh
and and ultimately they have no problem
in my opinion sacrificing whatever it
takes like a compromising or
jeopardizing the security of the whole
country
and all the while Sudanese live in fear
as more of their country is destroyed in
a battle for power rahila Muhammad
al-jazeera